ich habe mit großer überzeugung gegen
ihn gestimmt und ich muss ihnen ehrlich
sagen wenn er noch mal vier jahre
gewinnen sollte dann würde ich zum
ersten mal in meinem leben mit dem
gedanken ernst topspielen mein pass
zurück zu schicken denn das wäre
wirklich für amerika eine katastrophe
und was er hinterlassen würde nach vier
jahren wäre nicht mehr mein amerika aber
er schon das würden sie doch niemals tun
ernsthaft die drohung war neben ihren
pass zurückschicken das wäre doch
wahnsinn
nein wahrscheinlich letztendlich nicht
aber ich würde ernsthaft mit dem
gedanken mal zum ersten mal im leben
spielen also in erwägung ziehen
letztendlich würde ich wahrscheinlich
nicht machen
wer das nicht mehr ihr amerika wenn
jetzt noch einmal vier jahre das unter
dieser regierung laufen würde
nein es wäre nicht das land ist
gespalten wie sie es eben erwähnt haben
oder aus washington
ich meine was ist das denn für ein land
wo das weiße haus verteilt oder
verträumt ich weiß nicht wie man das
sagt also mit zaun abgeriegelt werden
muss vor der bevölkerung das ist doch
furchtbar
ein land das so gespalten ist und und
dann noch die spaltung so angefeuert
wird von dem präsidenten
das ist für mich undenkbar was geht
ihnen durch den kopf bei den aktuellen
bildern ich glaube sie können sie auch
gerade sehen die bilder dort in
washington vom weißen haus das sind ja
über daumen gepeilt und tausende die da
ganz offenbar stehen und teilweise
tanzen fröhlich sind aber eben hinter
diesen zahlen stehen müssen und drinnen
wartet dann der präsident auf sein
wahlergebnis was erleben sie bei diesen
bildern
ja die bürger kann ich heute im moment
nicht sehen aber sie haben es sehr gut
beschränken die situation
ich stelle mir die frage
deswegen sind die zäune da um um die
bevölkerung zu haus zu halten oder herr
drinnen zu behalten
also ich hoffe es ist das erstere also
es ist für mich unvorstellbar dass es
dazu in amerika gekommen ist und ich
glaube die einzige heilung wäre und zwar
indem man ein präsident bekommt der
verein nicht oder ein statt spalten dass
wir einen anderen präsidenten bekommen
woran das land und auch wo bemerkt die
republikanische partei gesunden könnte
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren